you know come watch me perform anytime
i'll perform no problem not only is
conor mcgregor denying that he got into
it with machine gun kelly at the 2021
mtv video music awards he's also
inviting the singer and his girlfriend
megan fox to his next fight what a way
to bounce back just in case you missed
it on sunday mgk was snapped by
photographers on the red carpet
seemingly getting into it with the mma
fighter according to an eyewitness the
two exchanged some words before conor
lunged at him i heard about the scuffle
you had with machine gun kelly on the
carpet
i don't know the man i don't know the
man he's obviously there's him and megan
to be at the at the fight so what
happened absolutely not then i don't
know i just i just showed up and i don't
know just i don't even know the guy but
when it caught up with conor backstage
he insisted nothing happened i certainly
don't fight little vanilla his boy
rappers you know i don't even know the
guy i don't know anything about him
except that he's making [ __ ] it didn't
look like nothing and word of the
alleged incident spread quick i heard
there was a fight with machine gun and
and
and uh conor mcgregor just over there
about two minutes ago so we were already
off to a good start then on tuesday the
33 year old extended an olive branch to
the paper cut singer while appearing on
adam glenn's adam's apple
good man come to the next fight then you
know come watch me perform anytime i
perform
no problem you know what i mean with
murder everyone's more than welcome to
come to my fight to come to the shows of
course mgk and megan regularly attend
big ufc events and were even caged side
for connor's fight in july and even
though the pics and videos from the
alleged incident looked pretty intense
the athlete doubled down and said it's
all good no obviously no people when she
go i don't even know the guy i don't
know him who is he telling me he's just
be at the fruits megan's been at the
freezer yes megan has been at the fight
fights years so i know megan and then
and then i i don't know i don't know how
to do it there's no problem come to the
fights
no problem as for mgk and megan etie
caught up with them shortly after the
alleged altercation went down at the
vmas and they didn't seem phased how did
you coordinate these outfits this
evening he was like you're going to be
naked tonight and i was like whatever
you say
daddy whatever daddy says are you proud
of him very proud he's the most talented
boy in the world